hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are talking
about
basically i got in an accident i came
off the motorbike at about 30 miles an
hour
directly into my hands and into one of
my knees
um and i couldn't walk for a few weeks
and
you know still can't do a tremendous
amount of cardio and as a result
gained more weight more rapidly than i
have ever gained before in my life
before we get any further into this
video i do have to tell you this video
is sponsored by raycon
which basically just means that i get to
do my own ad read in the middle of it
rather than youtube randomly putting ads
throughout the video about random things
wherever it wants but
we'll get to that so i already made a
part one of this video that i kind of
wanted to just make an update about
you know to kind of talk about it to be
candid about it um
and to help other people
hopefully uh you know this this is a
channel where i mostly talk about video
games but i feel like i always reiterate
it's not a gaming channel it
is a personal channel it can have
anything and everything on it i do not
advertise it as a gaming channel
but since most people here probably do
happen to be gamers since that's what i
like to talk about most of the time
i'm a big fan of trying to get gamers
into
fitness and health and so i thought that
i would kind of share some of the things
that i've been doing safely inside
during the pandemic to try to lose
weight
when i say lose weight for me personally
having gained
a significant amount of weight in a
small amount of time though this has
kind of spanned my whole life whenever
i've gained over a certain
weight effectively um i have asthma
and it puts more stress on my lungs so
this is something that's been consistent
throughout my whole life basically is
once i weigh a certain amount i tend to
get asthma a lot more frequently um
when i don't keep up with my fitness
going for a walk can give me asthma
where otherwise it might require at
least
a staircase so weight loss is not
something that i look at
as a thing that i'm doing out of shame
i'm not at all insecure about the way
that i look there are things that i
like about the way that i look right now
um and things that i like when i'm
a little bit smaller it's definitely not
that it all comes from a place of health
and i feel like i do have
a very healthy relationship with my body
and with trying to treat it
respectfully is the plan so the accident
was
in january um like i said i couldn't
walk for like the first
two weeks or so it was tough and i
gained weight really quickly
um my hands really still
i mean that's blown out as hell but you
can still see the scar here
and there's scar tissue that like
basically causes these huge ridges here
that um
my physical therapist told me to just
keep massaging out and my hands actually
don't hurt at all anymore um there was a
period where
i couldn't use them at all and then
there was a period where it hurt to play
video games like having too much
pressure on
a controller or on a keyboard was a
little bit too hard for me so i couldn't
really
use my arms all my legs very effectively
so now
my hands are still very weak i still
sometimes have trouble like
opening a bottle of some kind but they
they aren't in any more pain
and i do feel like these scars will
probably completely go away maybe
this this right hand will remain lumpy
but hey
i don't mind my knee however is still in
quite bad shape so i can't do anything
for too long
i still can't put weight on it i can't
do anything like a squat um
i can't really work my legs out and that
is a huge shame
because it's such a good way to get
sweaty honestly squats are
such a good exercise but i have found
some pretty good
alternatives that i thought that i would
share first though before i even talk
about you know
what i personally have been doing i just
kind of wanted to say the whole vibe
that i've been trying to share with
sharing this journey
is it's really just about trying to get
your heart rate up
for 30 minutes a day and maybe it's not
every day maybe you start with three
days a week but
you know as i said last time if you have
time to watch this youtube video
you have time to do some sit-ups you
have time to do some push-ups you have
time to go for a walk
you could use your lunch break there are
so many options to just kind of
try to treat your body correctly and for
me and i know this is very personal
people have different experiences you
can't just
paint everyone with the same brush um if
i'm having any mental health problems
working out is so good for me you get
those endorphins
and you feel good so uh
i've not been paying a lot of attention
to scales but i have lost weight so the
process
has begun even if i'm very limited
and i'm still treating myself i've still
had mcflurries and i have still had
oreos
all that good stuff i'm just trying to
mostly focus on making sure i eat a lot
of fruit and vegetables which
conveniently i enjoy i have a lot of
them in smoothie form
where i'll just mix in even stuff i
don't like just to get the nutrients
from it throw a celery in there tastes
like garbage
but it's good for you i'll say i don't
believe in diets i think that
restricting yourself excessively tends
to lead to failure if you're saying i'm
only eating these things i'm not eating
these things
people also tend to kind of starve
themselves and then screw up anyway and
for a longer amount of time so i don't
follow any diet i just try to eat
foods that have a solid nutritional
value
that have uh the nutrients that that are
good for me
but that doesn't mean i'm gonna
magically be able to say no
to chocolate over easter weekend okay
i'm not a superhero
and i don't feel bad about it and i
think that's the most important part
for the exercise portion which is more
of what i wanted to talk about in this
video
because these are video gaming options
boyos
outside of doing some very light weight
lifting which i
generally do while watching a
documentary or a tv show i will sit
there and i will do
you know bicep curls and shoulder
presses uh with a very light weight
because my hands can't handle much
though i will say
i only just started being able to lift
heavier
i went up a weight which feels so good
to have lost a lot of strength and to be
able to
like increase that weight good stuff but
yeah so i'll i'll uh
generally do muscle groups of my upper
body again because i'm still having
trouble really doing anything with my
stupid dumb legs
but i've also again and in a way that i
think is pretty sweet incorporated video
games into
a lot of my workouts so i said this in
the last video and i stand by it but
i've explored it a little bit further
that i think
vr is fantastic for working out
so i use an oculus quest i said last
time i'm a huge fan of beat saber
what i generally try to do is play
through all of the songs on expert
and if i fail i go to the next song and
then just keep playing through that way
i feel like it's a very good way to stay
engaged and motivated to try to get
through everything because you're like
basically playing through the hardest
levels on the hardest difficulty i think
beat saber is a great workout
um i can be really sore afterwards
sometimes i can get very frustrated with
the failure but i always want to go back
and i'm excited to go back and i think
that's a really important part of it as
someone who
hates cardio the other one that i highly
recommend which i have been able to do a
tiny bit of because they don't punish
you for
your squat level um is supernatural vr
which i think i also spoke about last
time
i love supernatural beer it it kicks my
butt it can be really really difficult
uh but it's so good you have a trainer
talking to you and encouraging you to
get through these songs kind of similar
to beat saber but it does seem to have a
little bit more of a workout focus with
a personal trainer who's talking in your
ear it is a monthly subscription because
you are basically paying these personal
trainers
to make new content every day uh but it
is a little bit pricey it is time to
tell you guys a little bit
about raycon raycon is disrupting the
electronics industry by designing
premium wireless audio for half the
price without the compromise genuinely
these things sound great and are really
comfortable i also really like the
design they definitely look very
different to all the other brands out
there
and just sit in your ears really really
neatly they offer their wireless earbuds
in a range of fun colors and
patterns with a variety of fit options
and no dangling wires or
stems they also definitely prioritize
their customer experience from start to
finish with
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing
more bass and a more compact design for
a comfortable noise isolating fit now as
is in line with this video i have mostly
been using them while going for walks
in some cases while doing yoga they let
me listen to an instructor via my pc
or my tv sometimes when i want to get in
those early morning or late night
workouts without disrupting anyone else
around me they're really comfortable
really sleek affordable and
they sound great so click the link in
the description box or go to buy
rakon.com
alana to get 15 off your recon purchase
and back to the video
another game that i only just started
using after this happened
which i think is pretty fantastic is a
fit
xr it basically combines dancing and
boxing into one
definitely a similar vibe to both of the
other two games i feel like it's a
little bit more like beat saber in
gameplay where it's like very much about
punching sort of
um whereas supernatural is more about
hitting so they do feel like different
emotions they are explosive to your
muscles in different ways
um but fit xr does also have personal
trainers who
talk to you as well one thing that you
can do that i know inspires other people
i definitely don't need this because i
like
workout time as being alone time in fit
xr
you can match in with people on
different places around the world so you
kind of get that community gym
experience where you could inspire
people or inspire each other is what i
mean another game in a similar vein
uh to those two again oculus quest or
i'm sorry i should have said i have
oculus quest 2 but i imagine they're on
both oculus quests and rifts i would
think
is uh o shape o shape basically gives
you
these cutouts um that you have to match
your body to so like different poses
that you have to match your body to
uh there are also periods where you do
have to do light squats but also still a
rhythm game where it like tries to make
you kind of dance to a beat
while matching these things and i think
this one stood out to me as being uh
unique and worth
also giving a shot if this is something
that you have access to
because recreating the poses is kind of
fun but
also is making me do movements that i
would not otherwise do in any of these
other games so it's definitely unique in
that way
so those are all like kind of more
traditional fitness games i guess beat
saber isn't and there are a lot of games
that are like beat saber that were
clearly inspired by beat saber like
synth writers
um but there are also action games that
i found have been
very good for making me sweat one of
these is a game called pistol whip
pistol whip still does sort of focus on
rhythm elements but it is an action game
you are shooting enemies in some ways i
was like
really close to the floor i was moving
around i was dodging stuff like it is
definitely
intense and gets intense really quickly
in a way that i totally forget
that i'm uh in the real world exercising
so pistol whip i thought did a really
good job of that and was something that
i hadn't
heard of that kind of thing before um
i'm sure a lot of people will already be
familiar with super hot which again
i think is a fantastic workout because
of a lot of that holding
uh if you've not seen super hot sorry
it's a bunch of enemies coming at you
but whenever you move
they move if you don't move time's
really slow so it's a lot of like
figuring out where people are
dodging at the right time waiting for
their bullet to pass you coming back
stealing something off them throwing
something at them
um again a game that is really fun even
without vr that game is fun
when you have vr a good way to get your
heart rate up just an awesome game in
general the last vr game that i wanted
to recommend is a game called
racket vr again another one that i've
only tried in the last month while
trying to get back into exercising
you're basically in this
giant dome and you have to very much
like a tennis or a squash
you have to hit a ball into a specific
target on one of the walls
uh kind of trigging the same exercises
that
we sports did with wii tennis it's a lot
of like these kind of motions a lot of
like hitting
you know everything that's overhead um
but
again something that when you're playing
in vr i think it's really easy to like
you know actually get
pretty explosive with those exercises uh
got sweaty super fast with this this one
is really simple
it does have a campaign it does have an
endless mode but was something that i
felt like you know for my arms and my
shoulders
was doing a wonderful job of getting me
moving though i will say it did have a
focus
on my dominant hand my right hand so uh
the others i feel like can be a little
bit more of both
with racquetball it feels a little bit
weird to do it with the left because it
is kind of like a tennis so
it was more focused on the right than
the left but also a lot of fun
so the other thing that i wanted to
mention which i think i had brought up
last video but not
tried yet was ring fit adventure it's an
exercising
action rpg on the switch that comes with
this circular band
thing uh that you have to move and i
will say that i think ring fit
because of the sense of resistance that
you get even from that band
probably was the most effective
workout that i got from any of these
unless i was like really trying hard
with uh racket or with fit xr because it
feels a little bit like having
more of a device for ring fit means that
you feel like you have to put more
strength into it whereas with the others
it's easier to just get
lazy and just like kind of sort of hit
stuff lazily you know
a lot better than i expected and i don't
know why i expected anything less
considering nintendo's history of
publishing pretty good fitness games
that is also a nice break from vr
because you can kind of only do so much
vr and of course not everyone has vr but
i feel like after a while like a vr
headset can start to hurt my head the
sweat like just feels gross because it's
on your face sometimes it feels a little
bit weird on your eyes ring fit removes
all of that
and will kick your butt in less than 10
minutes it's very very very good
i want to say thank you to all the
people who recommended it to me i'm a
really big fan so for anyone who's still
here i don't know
how many people are gonna make it this
far uh i wanted to talk about what we've
been doing with hashtag levelup2021.
essentially it's mostly on instagram
people are tagging me in their stories
and then i'm sharing them to try to get
encouragement
which i have 100 seen has encouraged
more people
to do these things so if someone's
working out they use the hashtag they
tag me and i share their story
i've had other people then say i saw you
sharing these stories and i decided to
jump on this train
and start working out and and getting a
walk in every day and i'm still seeing
people
every week be like hey i finally started
this alongside all of you and i think
that is
just the [ __ ] best just the coolest
that it's not just me who's doing it
it's everyone who's sharing it with me
that i can reshare and then
have a hundred thousand people see and
we just keep
increasing the cycle of people who are
trying to treat their bodies a little
bit better and get their bodies moving
so please keep doing that i really
appreciate it it's such a cool
way to like have this feel like a
community thing where you know every day
that someone tags me in a story
and i see it i go ah i wasn't going to
work out today
this person did i should and i'm also
getting ideas from the people who are
sharing this stuff the other thing that
i wanted to note
and i suggested this once before is
using my subreddit it's not mine it's
not official i do not mod it but it did
recently have a change in moderation
which makes me think that it is probably
a friendlier place than it was before so
if anyone wants to jump on the subreddit
which is uh
reddit.com alana pierce i
will also jump on there and talk to
people about this stuff
um specifically about level up 2021
about ideas about people
finding other video games that they can
suggest that can help people get fit
um anything along these lines i i really
want to encourage people to do
and i think it's a really cool community
effort for anyone who has been
joining so yeah everything's going very
slowly but well for me so far
very very slowly but i'm in good spirits
i'm healing that's the main thing but i
feel like i'm still on track
to get back into the very good shape
that i was in last year
alrighty i hope that this video was
useful to uh
anyone that it interested anyone
[Laughter]
i know fitness is a hard sell um but hey
you guys have been involved in this have
have made it easier for me so i really
appreciate that
thank you and i feel like you know maybe
when i'm back to the point that i want
to be at i'll post a before and after
picture
um but i do also try not to focus too
much on
how i look or like making it a negative
thing you know
try not to be like well this is the
before and the before is bad uh because
in my head it's just a change it's just
a different state of my
being so that is it for me today you
guys um i might do another one of these
updates probably not for a little while
maybe in a few months so if i'm like
back to where i want to be or if i've
learned anything new
this one just felt like because i had
actually you know made progress that i
should share huge thanks to raycon for
sponsoring this video check the link in
the description below to where you can
find out more from them and i will see
you guys next time
bye